so after cardi b took to the grammy
stage in what appeared to be
a costume from a never aired show girls
power rangers crossover film
and writhed about on a large bed while
lip-syncing to her x-rated hit [ __ ]
many people pointed out the obvious
irony here was a major pop star
flopping around on the stage screaming
about her genitals
during prime time on a major network
even as certain dr seuss books looney
tunes characters muppet films and disney
cartoons
have recently been criticized censored
or taken out of publication completely
for their supposedly objectionable
content it would seem that our culture
has a rather confused idea
about what sorts of material might be
damaging to impressionable children
or impressionable adults for that matter
now it might be more accurate to say
that our culture doesn't really care
about protecting kids from damaging
material
and only uses those concerns as a
vehicle to enact sweeping cultural
changes
either way the contrast between wap and
dr
seuss is as instructive as it is
depressing and it's also the kind of
conversation that would cause previous
generations
if they looked through a crystal ball
and overheard it to throw themselves off
of cliffs and mass
yet the really profound cancel culture
hypocrisy as it relates to cardi b
can be found not in her music but in
something else
recall that the singer only a few years
ago confessed on camera
to drugging and robbing men in a deleted
instagram video she boasted of having
lured men she didn't say how many but it
would seem that there were numerous
victims
from the strip club where she worked
back to a hotel room
where she committed these felonies
against them now the clip is kind of
hard to understand
but uh here it is again anyway listen
with my money
[Music]
[Music]
that's what i used to do
[Music]
truly a scholar is this woman
and she's trying to prove that she
deserves her success
by telling us that she is guilty of
multiple felonies
but i mean i deserve to be successful
i'm a criminal
that's the logic now in this video
resurfaced in 2019 cardi b addressed it
but never used the phrase
i'm sorry she merely admitted that she's
quote not a perfect person which may be
the only understated thing she's ever
written or said and explained that
whether or not they were poor choices at
the time i did what i had to do to
survive
whether or not they were poor choices
this is a justification not an apology
it's also a lie
in other interviews the rapper has
bragged that she earned upwards of three
thousand dollars a night
from stripping by the age of 21 she
claims she had 20 grand in singles
saved by 22 she was starring on a
reality show love in hip-hop new york
so when exactly was she so poor and
destitute that she had to drug and rob
people to survive it doesn't appear that
cardi b
views drugging and assaulting people as
any kind of serious action requiring
desperation to justify anyway
now even if she did view it that way
she'd be wrong but her own words suggest
otherwise in a different video while
dispensing some helpful relationship
advice
she said that if a man cheats on her
she'll quote take him out
drug him then enlist a quote [ __ ] her
words not mine
to sexually assault him while he's
inebriated this is again this is what
she said let's listen to that
cheat on me i'll be that guy i'm gonna
take him out we're gonna get drunk i'm
gonna get him
all perked up and everything we're gonna
have a good time
get him super twisted then bring a [ __ ]
around
we're gonna have a threesome and when he
wake up he's gonna be like what the [ __ ]
yeah because the [ __ ] was a [ __ ] i
mean like yup
yup we had a threesome with the [ __ ]
yep
yep
this woman's iq is i mean it has to be
at least double digits
now it's not clear if she's actually
done this herself or she's simply
recommending it as a course of action
nobody's thought to ask because none of
this has been judged important by our
cultural overlords
now a contestant on the bachelor
attended an old south themed frat party
in 2018
and that past infraction made it around
the same age when cardi b was committing
violent crimes that would land less
privileged people
in prison for three decades has been
judged so severe
that multiple tearful apologies are not
enough to rectify it
we've seen people canceled for tweets
and jokes and off the cuff comments
and other sins which cause no physical
harm or any other kind of harm to anyone
we've seen people lose their jobs and
their livelihoods for opinions they
expressed or words they said
no matter the context or intent or how
long ago it was
cardi b has survived all of those rounds
of cancelling the cancel mob has not
just
passed her over or looked the other way
but given her a pass
from all present and future
cancellations
she's afforded this privilege for
obvious reasons for one thing
the primary transgression that will get
you cancelled is having white skin it's
no coincidence
that almost every canceled person you
can name is white
cardi b has not committed that violation
so that's the first thing for another
the leftist cancel mob truly considers
an offensive opinion joke tweet or word
to be far more dangerous and evil than
drugging and robbing people especially
men
it's not as though they're they're
gritting their teeth and merely putting
up with cardi b
in spite of these terrible things that
she had boasted of doing no it's that
they don't care
or worse they love her even more for
sticking it to the patriarchy by means
of violent felonies
in a culture where feelings are king the
worst thing you can do even worse than
violent crime a lot worse
is have unapproved feelings or opinions
or to offend the feelings of someone who
has approved opinions
what all this means is that
uh well it means a lot but here's one
thing we can at least put to rest
the flimsy rationalization that cancel
culture is really a matter of
accountability
i mean if that's all the mob was doing
holding people accountable
then certainly cardi b would be in line
for a little accountability of her own
she might at a minimum be expected to
reach into the ample profits she's
earned from singing about her body parts
and repay the men she robbed that
wouldn't even come close to full
accountability full accountability would
involve her sitting in a jail cell
until sometime in the 2050s but it would
be something
instead we get nothing we focus on
holding random bachelor contestants
accountable for the frat parties they
intended
and newspaper editors accountable for a
single word they said on one instance an
entirely innocent context two years ago
while criminal sociopaths like cardi b
carry on making their millions
spewing filth into our children's ears
and never having to apologize for
anything
call that what you want but please do
not call that accountability
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content